I guess we are live oh good morning good
afternoon good evening depending on
where you are great to get together here
before starting and I didn't have a look
at it it's an amazing world we live in I
look at the people who are there waiting
and so I see that we have I don't know I
think I know that Michael Reese physio
is from the Philippines but I don't know
where Michael is located we have Mateos
from Brazil we have a Jose BA from Spain
asked them from Kazakhstan edwin from I
think he's Canadian amateur anyway it's
an amazing world we can be sort of
meeting with people from all over the
world meeting with each other chatting
with each other and of course the world
speaks lots of languages and never in my
experience my life has been easier to
learn languages and explore languages
and through languages travel around the
world and so today I want to talk about
learning more than one language at the
same time because it's something that I
get asked about all the time and
something that for a long time I said no
it's not a good idea because you need to
focus on one language you need to bring
so much intensity to the task because
you have to change basically you have to
change things in your brain and that the
sort of white heat of focus on on a
language exposing bombarding your brain
with with input in the new language
listening to it reading it reviewing
words and speaking it is just forging a
new sort of control center language
control center in your brain because
after all it is particularly when you
start out if you're a speaker of only
one language your brain is not so
structured to be able to speak that one
language so the new languages is a major
disruption it's got a different sound
different structures and and of course
you exist you know accepting these
different ways of saying things and by
the time you get to you third language
you're just a little more flexible but
still I found and certainly though that
was my experience with my first language
is French and then Mandarin Chinese and
then with Japanese I needed a lot of
focus in order to make these changes
happen in my brain so that I could then
naturally become you know comfortable in
the language but now after all I'm doing
two languages so look well I talk what
I'm doing and what the advantages or
disadvantages are of focusing on one or
doing two and then we can have some
discussion on the subject so if I were
if I have to write an exam in French
Chinese Arabic or whatever you know like
right now I'm doing Arabic and Persian
but if I have if I knew that I had to
write an exam in one of those languages
I would totally focus on one language so
you will achieve more over the same
period of time if you focus on one
language I definitely believe that and
if I have so three hours a day five
hours a day the more hours a day the
greater the intensity the better I will
learn and the greater range of
activities if I have to study five six
hours a day I would vary my activities I
can't just read and listen for five six
hours a day I would do more reviewing of
vocabulary I would be more righty I
would do more speaking everything more
translating I would do more different
things in order to bring some variety
into but still remaining focused on the
one language but I'm not in that
situation
I don't need Arabic for my work I don't
need Arabic for school so I am learning
these languages purely out of interest
purely out of a desire to explore parts
of the world that had been not so
familiar to me and and I find that
fascinating
have a completely different perspective
now on the Arab world or the history of
Persia the Iranian world and I'm
exploring the language and I'm enjoying
doing too and the advantage of doing too
is that there is a little more variety
so part of the problem say in Arabic is
the lack of intermediate material so you
get tired of either listening to or
reading the same beginner material for
the umpteenth time or sort of beating
your head against difficult content
where there are lots of unknown words
and you listen and still don't
understand so it's kind of nice
refreshing to leave that and then they
of doing that in Arabic and then I go
off to Persian Persian also has the
advantage of being a lot easier it's
just structurally closer to European
languages it's easier to read so it's
kind of nice so I'll do the Persian 4
and as I have explained before I go
Arabic for three and a half days or so
and then I go Persian so I kind of I'm
happy to kind of retreat back to Persian
which is he easier and then after a
while I kind of anxious to see to once
again take Arabic and so I think this
variety keeps things fresh for me and
yet at the same time you know I'm moving
along less quickly in both of them then
if I you know we're focused on what but
it really doesn't matter because you
know somebody commented I think on
Twitter that they have been encouraged
by me that they were a monolingual
English speaker and Sirius dumps about
being able to learn Russian and then I
talked about the need for patience and
the fact that we will eventually get
there and so I feel the same way when
I'm doing two languages
more slowly in each of those languages
but it doesn't matter the language isn't
going anywhere there's no deadline I can
continue to explore them I was listening
to an Arabic podcast this morning while
preparing breakfast so picking out words
that I didn't know before you know words
you know from politics or economics and
stuff so I totally understand the whole
thing but I'm picking out more words so
I said myself well I know those words
that I didn't know before I just have to
continue to pick away at it gradually
acquiring more words and I made the
reference in the previous video to Sir
jigsaw puzzle so as more words
slot into place more things will become
clearer so I'm not in a hurry and some
of the advantages like go I tweeted on
this you know you sometimes hear people
in the language teaching community
writing about false friends as if this
is some great problem that there are
lone words or words to say if you have
languages of the same language family
sometimes the word will have different
meanings the similar word will mean
something different in different
languages and that these are false
friends we think they're a friend we
think we know them and in fact we don't
know but I think false friends are a
tremendous advantage when I see Arabic
loanwords in Persian I then find it
easier to remember those words because I
I know roughly what they mean even if
the specific meaning in Persian is
different and so with enough exposure to
Persian enough exposure to different
contexts and content items I will start
to sort of define more and more how that
word is used in Persian what the meaning
is so doesn't matter to me that I might
get it wrong the first time if I meet it
enough times in different contexts I'll
actually figure out what it is but on
the other hand it's a lot easier to
remember so
friends are actually a good thing unless
unless you're trying to speak Geordie
and and obviously there will always be
things from other languages that
influence us might be our own language
and we always get the structure on
because we're influenced by our own
language
so what none of that matters to me
language is all about communication
communication with errors so so in terms
of how to study two languages what I
chose to do this time was to as I say
half the week on 1/2 a week on the other
in both cases there's a lot of work
required in terms of finding content so
I have to invest some time over the
weekend I took because I bought a signal
for Persian which is actually quite good
it's better than the Arabic the Arabic I
say meal is full of very hmm I would say
you know when you're learning a language
you don't wanna get too far into the
culture some poet from the fifteenth
century or some festival or you know and
three different degrees of relatives and
their hands and uncles and stuff
to me that's that this too too much into
the culture too early is not subject for
language learning it's easier to deal
with familiar scenarios get up in the
morning drink coffee go to work in the
car you watch television
so things that we already know that
we're familiar with from are from other
languages use those as your language
learning material so in that sense s
email with Arabic became too esoteric
and trying to be funny and cute whereas
the Persian as female is much more
sensible in my opinion so I enjoy the
Persian as a male much more than the
Arabic yes ago so I took the lessons 30
and above because there's very few
unknown words in the first even the
first 40 lessons now for me in Persian
smle but I then put them on this vocal
Matic website up and transcribe and I
uploaded them into my own personal
account
so I have no off 285 lessons from s
email waiting for me in Persian so in
Persian I've got Persian online lots of
good stuff I've got the SML waiting
there so I have a lot of material that
is there I can go to it anytime in
Arabic I'm sort of I have our many
stories and have who is she
I have I see mail but I don't like it
and then I have these podcasts than a
little difficult so I I try to bury it
bounce back and forth
the other thing is with Persia now I'm
speaking once a week because I have a
lot of good content to work through with
Arabic I'm not speaking twice a week
because I have with atutor
because I think I have I have better
comprehension in Arabic but I do need to
speak in Arabic has more issues of you
know verbs and masculine feminine tenses
how the verbs change which I find more
difficult so I I find it's good to try
and produce these things and then I get
a report back and then I start you know
trying to look for these different forms
when I'm listening and reading so did
that exhale I have a slightly different
strategy in Arabic than I have in Persia
before I forget to I have been asked to
look at the profile of a learner who
sent me his username at link and so
therefore it before we go to questions
I'm going to share the screen and let's
just see here and show you what one of
our learners okay shakes Creed and
starts creature so this is learner Gugu
toe foot who is learning Japanese so I
looked at the last six months so his
known words total is a little below the
target he has created lots of links he
has learned you know half the target
number
he has listened 60 hours compared to 90
hours he's done a lot of reading which
is very good he has done an awful lot of
writing which is tremendous and has
spoken 2.2 hours
so you know this would be very difficult
different from my profile I would have
far fewer hours of speaking although
that's not true in Arabic I'll have to
look up my numbers a little bit later ah
listening hours that's good I'm
surprised that I think if there are no
like normally if you're learning a
language like the European language
where there are a lot of words that are
easily identifiable then you're sort of
incidental no Lords total would be much
higher it's not the case in Japanese
where you kind of have to learn them all
individually because they're not really
related to anything not identifiable as
being similar to words and European
languages a bit if we look at say the
last three months which has been our
sort of 90 day challenge period known
word total is increasing he's creating a
lot of links lots of links to learn 60
hours of listening a hundred and
sixty-nine thousand words of reading
that's amazing list a lot of writing and
speaking is right up there so I'm very
impressed with basically the activity
level and a lot of these statistics are
largely a reflection of your activity
because if you stay active you're gonna
learn and I think that's one thing that
I really really believe like you know
I'm not in any rush with a Arabic or
Persian but I know that F F if I keep
doing it I will only get better and
seminar to hear this person to do don't
foot is very active and if you were
active you're gonna do well so just for
the fun of it let's see where we are
here if I go to my Arabic so I go to my
profile here
this is for the last several days so
you'll see that the em are looking here
at known words so as I indicated I
worked hard on Arabic and I go into into
Persian then I go back to era and so for
the last week I haven't picked up many
known words I'm largely going over older
material or I'm going into difficult
content where I'm not picking up any
incidental known words creating a lot of
links the listing I don't know that's
not very much I should be doing more
reading no writing to art speaking let's
look at the last three months
so here again also links lots of links
learn not so many incidental known words
33 hours of listening I'm certainly not
doing not as good as as don't foot
however I am doing two languages and not
doing a lot as much read one thing with
Arabic I'm having to read the same the
same lesson over and over again so I'm
not getting credit for that because I
forget I could add it when I read it to
the second time I could we have a little
plus sign in there I could add if I look
at you know that's the known word if I
look at my listing again it's the same
its cumulative it's of course increasing
but in the last of the while I've been
listening to a lot of Arabic last seven
days let's go last 30 days so that's
kind of what it looks like if I go to my
Persian here you know oh you lost your
streak repair your suite sure why not
you don't have an okay to that alright
so if I go to my profile here and these
are known words so the non words are
increasing but
let's go to the last 30 days so here
again last week let's go for the
three-month period here so no words
again because it's a not a related
language not so many incidental own
words
no words lots of links created lots of
links learn lots of listening lots of
reading lots of speaking but no right so
yeah that's just an example of my love
of activity stop this now and alright so
now let's see what sorts of questions we
might have here now Norris and I'm
learning kazakh Wow one day maybe Rancho
Cucamonga California I'm not sure where
that is but it's got to be near here
because I'm in Palm Springs hello from
Georgia you know we had some one-off
offer from Georgia to get some Georgians
together to do the mini stories in
Georgian so if we get that up there I
will certainly let you know honey on SEO
from South Korea Turkey I'm getting
there someday I will learn Turkish my
wife watches this Turkish soap opera on
Netflix hello from Taiwan ok India Wow
ok I'm okay on this challenge do you
have any advice to learn Swedish you
know I get asked this question all the
time I mean my advice where I learn
languages is that link and I talk all
the time about how to learn is listening
and reading we have content for Swedish
at link that's obviously going to be
what I recommend and I'm from China
okay I'm studying it's in Chinese and I
started reading these books and I
thought how many of course I need to
know to read on Chinese okay well if
you're gonna read Chinese first of all
you need a lot of characters but you
know I would try it
I have Eve
if I'm working primarily at late at
least four languages where I can read
them like say when I was doing polish
even though I couldn't you know there
were a lot of unknown words I can pick
up a Polish book because variety is nice
so while it's fun to do you know to work
on the iPad with Lync and looking at
words it's easier but then it's also
nice to read a book paper book but you
have to explore yourself get yourself a
Chinese book and see how well you do mmm
well I have here lost hope you know I
don't know anybody's flowing on the
teachers I'm a native Spanish speaker oh
yeah I still make mistakes I'm learning
things okay false friends are in this
town okay so have you finally you
struggle with listening more than
reading what is your advice beyond
listening more nice material I'm high
intermediate okay obviously listening is
more difficult than reading I can read
something online you know iPad
even if I don't look up the words when
I'm reading it I have more time I can
understand that when I listen sometimes
I don't
although I think now in both version and
Arabic I hear the words I hear the
sounds but I just don't know the words
and the only solution is just to
continue I found that in time you'll
understand more and more and I like to
read what I listen to I listen I don't
understand I read it and then I go
listen again and it's simply a matter of
continuing doing that it's easy to seem
fluent but it's hard to be fluid a
fluent doesn't mean perfect fluent means
that you can enjoy a conversation feel
comfortable in the conversation that the
person speaking to you with you feels
comfortable speaking with you and you
make mistakes and you look for words but
that's to my mind it's all fluid now to
some extent is flowing very fluid
extremely fluent but yeah
about the meaning of seem fluent but it
hard to be fun especially if you focus
on comprehension so there are people who
might sound fluent but they don't
understand what you're saying
that's not fluency fluency means you
understand what the person is saying if
anything your comprehension should be
better than your ability to speak
because you have to you can always make
mistakes and struggle to say things but
if you don't understand what the person
is saying it's very hard to have a
conversation can you show us the report
that you talked about getting from your
language partner also how do you decide
what to discuss in Arabic and farsi okay
let me show you a report no just a
second here and we're gonna click lingo
all right so if I go to tutors here and
I look at my activities so here are I've
lined up a bunch of you know
conversations and then I get my comment
is your report so let's look at the
let's view report so here's a report
from my persian tutor so she writes down
most of you can read this she writes
down a bunch of sentences and she adds
the audio I can import this so I already
have it important but I'll import it
again just to show you so this now comes
in as a lesson okay hey now there are no
more blue words here because I've
already been through it but I think
doesn't do it maybe do nesta okay so I
can listen to it while looking at it I
can listen to it away from the computer
I would save it to a playlist I can look
at it you know
here lots of words there and I can go
sentence view do where I can go this
wait a sec yeah so you know and it's
just content for me
so I study then there obviously you can
see by the number of words and phrases
that I upset here it's full of good
stuff for me so now let us go back to
tell you how it is
I'm not sure that worked
did that work desktop - ah I think it
never worked so let's start again
let's start again so this is the I'm
sorry about that let me just make sure
this alright again
so yeah let's go again tutors I go to my
activities and I go to our conversation
report here you were late nomination for
Google report and here you are lost
traces there's the audio there and I
click to import and it opens up a little
s so there you have it okay stop and all
right there I think that was a little
bit sorry for the confusion
all right no it is always a pleasure
boy can you show the report and how do I
decide what to discuss in Arabic and
farsi we just talk about anything
whatever comes up good tutor is able to
direct you to talk about things that are
of interest to you in an occasion I
especially earlier on and even some
extent now in Arabic we read together
because it's so difficult to read
because it's not like the Latin alphabet
it's there's not a sort of obvious way
how to pronounce and
learn if you have an hour today for
Chinese how much time would you spend on
character piece okay you only have an
hour a day well all I can say is when I
was doing it I was spending half an hour
to an hour a day on characters but I had
seven hours a day now if I have an hour
a day I think I would probably bunch it
up I go an hour on characters every
three days but then do a lot of
listening and reading so that I'm
constantly being exposed to the language
and in the reading exposed to the
characters uh holy richard has a good
who's on YouTube of all the steps he
took to learn Italian all the way
through to going to Val you might wonder
what sparked his fluency equal to being
able to speak your target language as
well as you speak English or they're
near no certainly not you you you don't
you know I speak French very well I
don't speak French as well as I speak
English I have very good comprehension
but obviously it's it's English is just
natural okay
so fluent is you know how big is the gap
well use the European common framework
absolute fluency if you're an educated
person is C 2 and C 2 plus and fluency 2
medias B 2 so there's a long gap in
terms of comprehension in terms of your
ability to express yourself precisely
without having to work around the words
that you're comfortable using so there's
a big difference what's the average
period to learn a language firstly
there's just too much vagueness there
average how many hours and they learn a
language which language how well they
learn the language I always find these
questions are how long does it take and
so forth not that helpful get engaged in
a language get learning and get liking
it and you will continue to improve haha
I always forget the t-shirts okay ah I
see every pair Joe I'm a native English
speaker learning three new languages
Russian Japanese Maude
the Hungarian while actively maintaining
Spanish okay well you are a hard worker
the children shows for beginners I don't
like children skills I don't like
children's stories I'm not that
interested in them and they're not
necessarily easier because there's a lot
of vocabulary that's not relevant to me
as an adult
oh yeah I say oh okay previa is Belarus
II okay all right
and you clearly have to hard as
necessity sometimes it doesn't mean
profession it most how to get the most
out of the tutors well it's it's an
opportunity to speak more than you know
so don't have this cuter do all the
speaking and let the tutor give you a
chance to speak force yourself to talk
about things that are difficult for you
to talk about because you don't have the
vocabulary and when you get the report
back from your tutor you'll be able to
work on those words and phrases it's an
opportunity to create some content that
you can use and don't worry about making
mistakes basically that's it
most of the tutor suggests that thinking
in English to speakers happening is the
right way to improve English how can we
identify okay all this business about
you know try to force yourself to think
in the language you're learning I don't
agree with it's a there's a natural
progression and initially we translate
from our own language or from a language
were more familiar with and in time we
do less and less of that it's not really
something that we can control is
something that naturally happens if we
have enough content I sort of input in
the language enough listening and
reading and vocabulary gradually we
start to produce these phrases naturally
it's not something we can consciously do
he said the word density is lower movies
and shows
is that ever offset by time saved by
getting meaning through visual cues yeah
I mean what are you trying to achieve
with the movie if you're trying to
understand the movie you understand a
pheromone through visual cues but if
you're hoping that the language is gonna
stick with you I have found that yeah
there's some benefit you hear some word
with and then the visual cue helps you
understand what that word is and you
pick it up but I find that I have to see
a word I have to hear it I have to see
it and to that extent listening and
reading is is more efficient not to
mention the fact that it's more portable
I can't be watching a movie while
driving a car for example I mean when it
comes to meet a tutor how to get the
most out of him as I say just let the
tutor bring the language out of you it's
on the tutor the tutors getting paid in
most cases so the tutor has to get you
to speak has to find things of interest
keep the conversation going be
encouraging not you know some tutors
would express a sort of you know
impatience if you get something wrong
that's very bad the tutor has to make
you feel comfortable and and if your
tutor isn't doing that find another to
another tutor that encourages you that
gets you talking and that's it's more on
the tutor mmm-hmm
hi Steve I'm learning Greek do you have
any tips or advice well I learned Greek
at link I have I paid to have our mini
stories translated and recorded we have
a fair amount of content on Greek ethnic
I would go there and my advice is always
the same lots of listening reading and I
love learning Greek and I learned it off
before going to visit Crete I tried to
cast a link so often but it doesn't work
okay you will have to contact customer
support lots of people cancel every day
we every day we have new people joining
and some people canceling it's not
difficult to do but if you have an issue
please contact customer support at link
dr. febray video should I learn to read
an Arabic first of all I mean it's
impossible to understand it at the end
link if I can't read the text yeah I
mean I struggled with this it's so I
downloaded a bunch of stuff on the
Arabic script and at first it's
extremely difficult like so much in
language learning I'll never get over
this this is impossible
Arabic script it's got the different
form depending on whether it's the
beginning in the middle of the end of
the word now I don't even notice those
things I just know what the letter is
may not know how to pronounce it or I
may not know the vowel in there I may
not be able to pronounce the word
accurately but I know of al it so you
just have to go through it what I found
very helpful initially it was for righty
so for example I use the dictation
function in our activities set up my
Arabic keyboard on my iPad and I had to
type the Arabic and so you just have to
put in the time but yeah you have to
work on learning to read but you can do
that in conjunction with you know the
content link Oh
take a deep breath how'd it get
enthusiastic about learning French from
scratch how'd it get enthusiastic I mean
you have to find something about the
language that interests you or a person
movie music something that'll make you
enthusiastic you can't force enthusiasm
don't turn okay Chinese characters how
many would you learn by a rope before
you try to learn them three well I don't
know about rope but I had a thousand
characters that I worked very
deliberately at learning the thousand
most frequent characters I had a
cardboard flashcards and I had a whole
system of reeling them and writing them
and I I deliberately went at learning
those first thousand characters but I
was reading and listening at the same
time Steve position he Dow in the wind
okay
I see I have a conversation I think one
year ago Amelia my niece improved so
much since then
okay now how do you balance your time on
reading listening and reviewing words
largely a matter of mood at the moment
obviously if I deliberate time I'm gonna
read and possibly review every page in
the lesson the rest of my every learning
time is in the car doing dishes working
out wherever I am and I have my air pod
plugged in my ear and I work no not no I
don't at the present time work as a
tutor could you give me some tips for
learning French I mean all these tips on
how to learn basically it's not specific
to any language it's the same idea with
French you have to focus on the fact
that that the the the sort of liaison
you know Comte I knew it whereas you
know what would be like whereas the
ending might be oh if there's a tea
there it's dawn like carries on to the
next you got to really get a handle on
the liaison sounds from one word to the
next and another I think people don't
necessarily focus on is that the e is
actually an earth so that hood sound
carries through in French pronunciation
is a lot of I can't get in the detail
here but fundamentally there's no
difference learning French learning
Chinese our policy I can you get fluent
in a language that going to the country
people say that you can call yourself
good if you can live in the zoo with the
animals okay you can get fluent in a
language that going to country I believe
that when I lived in Hong Kong I learned
Mandarin to a level b2 at any rate so
fluid I was quite comfortable I could go
into China at the Canton trade fair in
1969 1970 and translate for Canadian
businessmen who were up there doing
business with China I wrote a book on
language learning and I went to China
and gave speeches to Chinese
universities leading language schools
no pain my yeah
waddle - yeah - John - yeah
these are universities and I met
students there who had never been out of
China who were absolutely fluent in
English Japanese French and yeah that
means - I mean Chinese immigrants in
Canada we've been there for 30 years you
can't speak English so it's not am a
function of where you are it's obviously
an advantage if you're surrounded by the
language but it's not a condition you
can be surrounded by the language not
learn you can be in an area where they
don't speak the language and you can
learn okay I mean how many can I speak
ah you know I have some understanding of
now without being a person up to 20
languages probably ten of them I can
just turn on and speak the others I
would need varying degrees of warm up to
languages at the same time that's what
I've been talking about I'm working on
Persian and Arabic right now and I am
making progress in both of them I would
make faster progress if I were focused
on one but I am enjoying doing both ah
and I know anything what are your
thoughts on Benny stuff not using the
books and going outside and learning
this treaty way many claims it works for
him I just don't see it if I were to go
- I don't know Morocco I got up to
someone in the street and just start
using a few words of Arabic I talk about
yeah who who has the patience to humor
me
unless I pay them as a tutor I just
don't see it I think you have to get the
language in you from outside it has to
come from a source a book book and audio
or a speaker and you have to somehow be
able to get that in you and make sense
of it and develop that comprehension
before you can just go out and speak
could you speak a little more slowly
okay I will speak more slowly ah
so rich
his friend is working on the many
stories should be done in a week or two
thanks for the help okay thank you rich
for organizing these Georgian mini
stories how to develop a language core
before starting reading you know the
reading gives you the language reading
and listening I don't believe there is
such a thing as a as a language core the
basics that you've got this sort of
foundation in the language and now
you're gonna go ahead and learn it you
are learning it as you are reading and
as you are listening as the fundamental
concepts in the language you will
continue to get wrong
for a long long time so you don't nail
down the basics but you gradually become
more and more familiar with the language
somewhat like the jigsaw puzzle if I
find someone to do the Hungarian many
stories you can yes just send me an
email steam at link comm and I will send
you the mini-story file and if you can
get someone to do them in hungarian the
audio has to be clear oh one thing I
should point out and also for riched
ideally because in some languages mail
let assertiveness words change depending
on whether the speaker is male or female
so ideally we would have both male and
female narrators and it's obvious from
the story and these are typically done
on a Android or an iPhone that sound
quality is good enough as long as the
first piece probably a good idea to give
us a sample of the audio before you get
too far along but send me an email
steve at link com
can you learn language that books are
learning through the environment yeah I
don't I know I like books what do you
recommend the name is literature
difficult for me to say
because it's a matter of what people are
interested in like personally I like
19th century literature I enjoy Balzac
in French I enjoy Kurganov in Russian
but some people don't like that some
people like modern so it's really a
matter of of what you're interested in
and I would recommend finding books say
in literature where you can access both
the audiobook and the ebook even if you
have to pay for them because an e-book
you know that's a lot of learning
opportunity there I did that for Polish
for Ukrainian you can bring them in to
link as books and then you can work
through the words and phrases and then
go away and listen to the audiobook ok
is harder reading these novels than
technical and science books of course it
is
novels are very difficult that's yeah
the easiest is history or newspapers and
stuff like that but technical or science
books are easy only if you are from it
and they're with the subject matter if
you're not in you know familiar with
those scientific or technical contexts
it's not so easy at all yeah so keep it
real yes to send me an email and I will
get you the file do you think
differently when you speak many
languages I don't know hello Steve could
you give some tips to learn grammar and
how to deal with grammar drills the way
I deal with grammar drills is I don't do
them I gradually get a sense of the
language by learning words and phrases
and so that naturally I start to produce
the language more and more accurately I
remember with German when I stopped
trying to memorize the case endings my
German improved you know Russian there
are things there like the aspect of
verbs verbs of motion cases no matter
how much you study the rules
the tables you're never gonna nail it
down until you have absorbed enough of
the language that you gradually become
more accurate hello Steve I'm going to
trip depressant a stuff core has
learning what aspects of a language I
should focus on leading up to the trip
whatever okay I mean I would say go on
find things of interest I don't know
your level I I would go and look at
what's in our library at link if you are
beyond that level going by an audio book
where you can find the corresponding
ebook and where you like the voice of
the narrator and just get the language
in you and that way you will come to
France understand what people are saying
and you'll be able to progress progress
more quickly you know unfortunately
Arabic script is so tiny I just can't
read this on the fly do you speak no I
drove it in language I don't but I think
we had someone offered to provide us the
many stories in that language and if we
get that we will put it up as a language
in the link is YouTube a good place to
learn it Chinese sure it depends what
your interests are if you have a Chinese
YouTube video with subtitles in Chinese
these can be imported into link as
learning material okay I like his rain I
know Keith Swain is a good friend of
mine a very nice person can you attract
women by speaking their native language
what can I say though I can give it a
try I do not mean to bother you but one
of the admins has talked about posting
detonation time many stories a month
about a month ago are you still planning
on this it's the same if we get the many
stories done of a sufficient quality we
will put them up I don't think we have
received this in Vietnamese or Thai yet
okay I made Mohammed I'm having language
burnout at the moment then just leave it
how'd it go from b1 to b2 it's a long
road but hopefully you're starting to
access interesting content so that it's
as long but enjoyable Road
as you discover interesting things
through the language can you get fluent
in Italian and six months if you already
know Spanish absolutely I think that's
very doable why do you think Japanese
are not good at learning languages I'm
Japanese okay first of all I always I
don't like the sort of generalization
Solon's so like I heard the Chinese are
no good at learning languages when I was
in China and the students at university
were phenomenal
[Music]
you know I think there are problems in
Japan in the way the languages are
taught
I think katakana is a problem because
katakana is for those not familiar is a
in Japanese they have the Chinese
characters country they have hiragana
which is a phonetic script based on
syllables then they have a parallel
phonetic script for foreign words for
example now because it's a syllable
based script tahqiq okay cool
therefore it doesn't break it down into
K a car's car so therefore it's very
difficult to effectively represent a
word in English using katakana so any
job so if the Japanese person C is a
word in English oh how is that
pronounced then they read the katakana
very bad very bad the only way to get
around that is to basically remove
katakana from any language instruction
rely on either the Latin alphabet but
that's not gonna mean it the English is
in the Latin alphabet
unfortunately English is not very
consistent in how it's written mind you
the question was not just English the
question was learning languages so yeah
get rid of katakana do a lot of
listening reading which is quite popular
in in Japan and and then but but I think
in Japan two other things I find that
there's a lot of this sort of a chi-wah
emphasis is sitting around and just
talking that's not going to improve you
very much if you're sitting there with
five other Japanese people and the third
of it is
tremendous focus on tests toach and
these other tests i think that they
should focus entirely on comprehension
enjoying the language reading and
listening and then when you go to speak
just speak but overcoming the katakana
handicap is probably a major reason
Steve it's not the case in German but
there is a question of formal with older
people versus informal with younger
people what should be used in the
translations you know what is the
average person what that's a good
question because I would go for the
informal quick answer I would go for the
informal because I don't think a
Georgian is going to be in offended if a
foreigner speaks in formal way and the
many stories are just a place to get
started and anybody who is going to
learn Georgian will be exposed to a lot
of additional content so they'll learn
earn one farm through the many stories
and gradually they'll pick up the other
farms I've always you don't want to be
too casual I was fine then if you can
get a neutral version of the language
it's not too slangy and yet at the same
time not too far mall I mean it comes up
in Japanese in the same way just go for
sort of the way most people would speak
in typical everyday situations if that's
helpful
okay so there's nothing you need to do
before you start meeting well yeah
that's why you work at link you hear 30
seconds you try and read it you look
upwards and I gradually you're taking
out fights that are 30 seconds 60
seconds minute and a half two minutes
that's the whole process well you know
are there days when I lack motivation
yeah some days I'm more motivated than
others but there are easy things to do
like just listening or you know if I'm
if I'm reading you know it's tiring for
me
Narvik so I make sure I have the sound
on so I'm just following along so I'm
kind of cheating because I'm hearing the
word so I'm not forcing myself to read
it but if I'm tired then that's gonna do
that and I find that quite enjoyable
varying your activities is a good way to
be motivate but if you're completely not
motivated then don't do it
ah Steve we Italian - Mina yeah shall
Tac Toe rather yak show me so oh yeah
okay I will look up that and I saw
Mironova
Meno and and thank you doctor
we're having friends or a girlfriend
help you learn a language faster no but
having friends and the girlfriend is
good it's good thing to have friends no
all joking aside if that person your
friend girlfriend friend is used to
speaking to you in a language other than
the language you're learning they may
not help you very much but if they will
agree to talk to you in the language
you're learning
of course that's helpful drugs I'll see
ya okay - yeah I love link but sometimes
I want to read from real books how much
should I understand to get something
else should I write down translate oh
yeah I - certainly like reading robot
when I read real books I don't look
anything up it's a it's you know variety
is good doing things using different
materials its roof rates relaxing to
read a book but when I read a book my
experience has been looking up the word
I never remember it I write it down on
listen up review the list so I just read
and whatever I get out of it I get out
of it ah
can I start two or three languages at
the same time you know you can try
anything and see what you're comfortable
doing
I started Arabic first then Persian I
don't think I would start two languages
at the same time from scratch I wouldn't
do that but maybe it works for you okay
I don't know enough about AG ATT and
katsumoto
comment have you find that you have you
found the II struggle with more
listening or reading reading is more
difficult I think I answered that okay I
don't with regard to Moses I don't know
the details of his learning the proto I
only know that he is very successful and
has learned many languages and has a
very nice relaxing star new home team in
ten seconds I shall mama I don't
understand okay do you think that
vocabulary is the most difficult part of
learning any language no nothing is
particularly difficult but the
vocabulary is important it's key you
need to build up a large passive
vocabulary some of which eventually
becomes activated how discard from
scratch especially French again link
because what has beginner material read
it listen to it look up words and just
keep doing that hamster do you consider
it weird to try to practice with people
at any chance possible I don't do it I
don't want to say it's weird I just
don't do it thank you for your videos
give me a motivation should be always
write on paper the words we just learned
I never do okay good with that I'm gonna
call it so thank you very much and yeah
we'll be back together on Wednesday bye
for now